Oh
all right gentlemen here we are in
Sacramento California at the state
capital not only a beautiful building
but a place that welcomes me with open
arms is where I was giving my day let me
worry 22nd is kevin hart day this is
where it all happened your day my day
breathe it in
who told you to stop by everybody did
cuz I came and I wound people follow me
and wipe your feet off before you go
inside outside still I got at all I was
like mama how glad you went Kevin Hart
look I don't just say I'm a big deal
around these parts guys I show you read
it that's the senator okay it's a little
hole my friend okay you know you ain't
got a do I do own induce you let me use
you just relax Silver City the hole is
Oh senator okay what's up bro how can I
help him barber school on what's going
on I want to do to my friends yeah
that's hairy right there I call him
bucket low that's Joey right there good
friend of mine man we do a lot of work
together I want to show these guys the
ropes
I'm Jimmy yeah give me one second hold
on before you go let me know one second
okay a second hey make security okay
security hey you got you already know
you need you back up I'm here no he
called security
yeah so I'm making sure he okay no no no
no you all right thinking condom on you
when you well you didn't call them hey
hey though yeah I'll see you a little
car whoa we got to go um you know i'ma
call your phone come on let's just let's
just go
you